it's a moment of change
representatives of lebanon's protest
movement making their way to parliament
they walked past security forces who
once kept them out during massive
demonstrations in recent years
it's the first session of the newly
elected legislature and these first-time
mps are hoping to bring change to a
decades-old system
there is no democracy in lebanon with
the consociational and confessional
system but we are here to reinforce
democracy in lebanon and to reinforce
human rights we're gonna refuse any any
kind of compromises
compromises based on power sharing
between the political establishment have
long been how politics is done here
that's how parliamentary speaker nabi
beri was re-elected
he has been in the position for three
decades and for many a symbol of a
failed system riddled with corruption
but this time it was different bury
failed to get the endorsement of a
majority and one with the slimmest of
margins
a blow but symbolic
for those who are hoping for radical
change that hasn't happened change mps
couldn't win enough seats the status quo
didn't change
and it's lebanese leaders who have been
in power who are expected to have the
final say on what's next
the vote for a new speaker starts a
constitutional process that includes the
formation of a new government and in a
few months the election of a new
president but the current landscape in
parliament the lack of a clear-cut
majority means there could be protracted
negotiations
an extended political vacuum won't help
a state and an economy that has all but
collapsed
the parliament has failed over the years
to implement or undertake any economic
reforms for that matter and during the
crisis in fact the parliament obstructed
economic changes and economic reforms
politicians are also accused of
obstructing accountability for the
beirut port explosion that killed more
than 200 people two years ago
the state killed my brother they are
responsible and we want to know the
truth
those who are confronting the system no
democratic change cannot come overnight
but today's vote appears to be the
beginning senator al-jazeera beirut
let's bring in jawad adra who's a
lebanese political scientist and analyst
and the founder of information
international he joins us now live from
beirut what do you make of the
re-election of lebanon's
speaker a man who's been in this job for
30 years
well this is the seventh time and yes it
is you're correct
i think really the question is what
should we make of what is the future of
lebanon
and this is the issue i don't think the
uh
you know we all watched i think the
election it's the process is nice and
it's good that we
uh that you know we are in a middle
eastern country where we have election
every four years and we have a
parliament and so on but is this
democracy
this is a question is this the life
that we want
we are a bankrupt company
and we have the same ceos still running
the company
the country really is facing existential
threat and the question is
how do we
come out of this
you know
so
how can we stand up again that's the
question
what are people
going to think the people all those
protests we saw
uh in in beirut some of them quite
violent people thoroughly thoroughly fed
up with the political classes and their
standard of living
what are they going to make of this of
this new parliament where as you say
you've got the same
ceo running a bankrupt company
uh first i think we have to really look
at what happened uh in uh
two you know two and a half years ago
and uh
when the protest started
was it a revolution we called it saura
it was not a revolution and it was not
thorough so we have to really fix our
terminology
as if
do we have democracy no we don't have
democracy
as one one time dr house former prime
minister said he said in lebanon we have
a lot of freedom
but we have little democracy
we don't have accountability
the people are
marginalized the majority of the people
you have
we're talking about roughly four and a
half maybe million
uh residents in lebanon lebanese
residents
half of those have always been
marginalized they are poor
and now maybe they are benefiting a
little bit from the ngos that are
distributing some aid
so these guys
don't count in a way in the political
power
you have the middle class that has been
destroyed
and most of them have immigrated or are
you know secluded
we are left with a society that is not a
society really we are left with uh with
with a very
awkward
population
on a piece of land
we claim to be a society we claim to be
communities we're neither communities
nor the society and the point is do we
have the vision to rebuild this country
and to you know to have to have new
founding fathers yes you you paint a
very depressing picture
how does change come about though in
lebanon
we have to have a common vision are we
united in our vision how to come out of
this we're not
we claim you know we we are so proud be
at the political lords of lebanon all
the new guys who just entered the
parliament
when they they are proud to have to say
you we have foreign support
we have you know i have good connection
with this country for this country
instead of saying let's focus on us
we have to have a common vision in
lebanon
as lebanese
how to come out with this and then after
we start our own reform process we don't
ask for prescription from outside for
reform we don't need lectures from
the outside about you should reform we
know we should reform
but we have not done this and we are all
responsible as population and as
politicians
good to talk to you sir many thanks
indeed